you need white down
what's with the jeans so Christine are
you doing Starbucks Ron yeah what do you
want you um I want a venti iced coffee
mm-hmm extra ice a splash of soy okay
after write that you got right back down
that's a ridiculous way it's not a
ridiculous order to order make sure it's
a ton I don't happens every other time I
ask for extra eyes I pick it up and
there's four pieces eyes oh my god I got
a I thought I said lightnings your order
is already too complicated how does that
complicate your ask did you say Splenda
- no no Splenda I put it on myself
that's smart cuz I don't want to do it
for you that's what I do it was crazy
so venti iced coffee extra ice yeah
small splashes oh it's so stupid okay
here how is that stupid I can't fucking
I don't even know what day it is right
now I slept just turn all right the kid
right down you know I can't think head
mommy brain
this is ridiculous ringing order how is
it that the most or the worst because I
want hours at Starbucks I hated people
like you you're the weren't asking for
extra ice no the whole thing in a splash
of soy because if you say no they go no
I don't even say something I go listen
listen
Oh a small splash you as small is very
small look at you look at him Wow
someone's got to Netflix specials may
act like a king uh-huh what's going on
mostly stories geez
bujji now mr. splash you compare me to
Maria's orders yes oh yeah see it runs
in your family I should play you a
special phone to send you an audio file
of what Maria order you can you can tag
here wish you ordered your is so in the
security you guys in your coffee and top
dog with his McDonald's coffee that's
kind of in the world the worst it'll
worse look at them look at this order
that's not crazy this writing is like a
chicken a chicken's ass hole wrote it
something like my dog wrote this hey
what is it how do you write you write in
your left hand
of course so ridiculous
as 3 beverages if it well the morning
the morning before noon it is a single
bag
venti with three and awake tea with
three inches of steamed soy and three
raw sugars and then you add negative
responses in vanilla powder what I do it
it is afternoon summer that I do event I
detest oi sugar-free caramel
opportunitites
those extra drizzle and EasyWeb must be
the drizzle not the zero and if it's
afternoon and fall or winter then I do a
single bag Compu noventa cup with three
washer just three into the steamed soy
and foam and then topped off with three
splendas and vanilla powder that's right
so ridiculous it's so delicious